I had a version of that Reckoning at at  40 and it was sort of a collision of a  health scare with an existential crisis  about how I was living my life I was a  corporate lawyer at the time and very  unhappy but also very much in the  checking the boxes and you know trying  to make sure that I was the dutiful son  to parents with high expectations Etc  and had to you know really deconstruct  all of that and figure out who I wanted  to be and then spent a decade trying to  figure that out a modality that I  leveraged was Endurance Sports and all  of the kind of quiet time that comes  with that that allowed me to you know  develop a level of self-connection that  I was lacking at the time and ultimately  leading me into a more intuition-based  heart-centered place to be open to what  was next and you know slowly other  opportunities came and that's kind of  why I'm sitting here today